Рельтати розслідування так званого "вагнергейту" групою міжнародних журналістів Bellingcat в Україні чекали.
Але ефекту бомби воно не спричинило.
Розслідувачі, по суті, підтвердили уже відому українським слідчим органам інформацію без надання нових доказів.
У розслідуванні Bellingcat стверджується, що керівник Офісу президента Андрій Єрмак
запропонував відтермінувати спецоперацію із затримання членів ПВК "Вагнер" на тиждень
через досягнення домовленості про припинення вогню на Донбасі.
Наприкінці липня торік влада Білорусі повідомила про затримання 33 членів ПВК "Вагнер".
У ЗМІ одразу з'явилася інформація, що більше половини з них воювали на Донбасі.
Тож Україна, зокрема Володимир Зеленський особисто, просили Мінськ видати їм російських бойовиків.
Правитель Білорусі Олександр Лукашенко спершу погодився, проте у підсумку Білорусь все ж передала їх Росії.
Згодом низка ЗМІ повідомила, що операцію із затримання "вагнерівців" готувала розвідка міноборони України та СБУ.
Вони мали вилетіти з Мінська до Туреччини, однак літак здійснив би вимушену посадку в Києві, де "вагнерівців" затримали б.
Про операцію начебто повідомили президенту Зеленському та керівнику ОП Єрмаку.
Згодом з'явилася інформація, що причиною зриву спецоперації українських спецслужб
став, власне, наказ саме з Офісу президента відтермінувати затримання "вагнерівців".
Підозри посилило й те, що в ОП спершу взагалі заперечували факт операції, а потім заявили, що це була "ідея інших країн".
У розслідуванні Bellingcat докладно описано, як саме українські спецслужби блискуче спланували і виконали половину спецоперації.
Зокрема, зібрали дані про сотні "вагнерівців", завербували російського офіцера, який під час операції влаштувався до міноборони Росії.
А також організували доставку бойовиків спочатку в Мінськ, а згодом, як планувалося, до Києва.
Ви читаєте цю статтю як блокбастер, і те, що операція була зірвана - це абсолютно злочин.
І не тільки проти наших спецслужб, а й проти України, проти людей, які сподівалися, що у нас могла бути така величезна перемога, як у країни.
Уявіть, який це міг би бути ляпас Путіну, просто уявіть!
У звіті Bellingcat йдеться, що напередодні зриву операції була зустріч українських розвідників з Андрієм Єрмаком.
За свідченнями тодішнього керівника Головного управління розвідки,
Єрмак запропонував на тиждень перенести операцію через острах зірвати перемир'я на Донбасі, про яке Зеленський саме домовився з Росією.
Однак окрім слів колишнього очільника ГУР, інших підтверджень розмов журналісти не знайшли.
Утім, чи справді ці кілька днів могли якось вплинути на домовленість між Києвом і Москвою?
Юрій Бутусов, який першим в Україні почав говорити про зрив операції Офісом президента, дуже в цьому сумнівається.
Навпаки - затримання "вагнерівців" посилило б позиції України на переговорах.
Близько 300-400 осіб знаходяться у тюрмах, підвалах в руках російських спецслужб.
Українські військові, розвідники, невинні люди. Війна вже йде.
Результат такий: у нас немає на кого міняти наших полонених і заручників. Гинуть наші люди.
А в той час хтось у Києві  вирішує: "ви знаєте, а давайте ми 28 російських терористів відпустимо".
Розслідування Bellingcat підтвердило, що Зеленський і його оточення знали заздалегідь про масштабну спецоперацію.
Однак міжнародні розслідувачі так і не вказали, яка була реальна причина перенесення, а фактично - зриву операції.
У генпрокуратурі України запевнили, що українське слідство вивчить матеріали групи розслідувачів Bellingcat щодо операції із затримання "вагнерівців".
Однак виникає питання: якщо справа не рухалася досі, то чи допоможе міжнародне розслідування?
У цьому розслідуванні є речі, на які мають відповісти українські правоохоронні органи.
А вони за понад 15 місяців, жодних заяв не роблять, жодних висновків не зробили.
Я навіть не кажу про те, щоб вони визнали зрадника чи злочинця.
Вони навіть не виявили те, чи є склад злочину.
Навесні 2021 року у  Верховній Раді створили Тимчасову слідчу комісію щодо вагнерівців.
Однак її висновками залишилися незадоволені, оскільки жодної нової інформації там не оприлюднили.
Очільниця опозиційної партії "Голос" Кіра Рудик вважає, що попри резонанс,
журналістського розслідування буде недостатньо, аби це мало якісь юридичні наслідки.
Я хочу наполягти на тому, що журналістського розслідування тут недостатньо, щоб мати юридичні висновки, з якими можна рухатися далі.
Тому все одно має бути ТСК, яка складається з депутатів, вона має слухати всіх представників цією влади,
і вона має дати свої висновки, саме вони можуть бути і підставою для подальших юридичних кроків.
Українські розслідувачі неодноразово робили припущення про "злив" інформації російським чи білоруським спецслужбам
після візитів розвідників до Офісу президента.
Однак у розслідуванні Bellingcat про це не йдеться.
Є бажання влади приховати злочин і покарати тих, хто воює з Росією, хто завдає удари російським спецслужбам.
Висновки очевидні. І у мене є всі підстави стверджувати про залучення людей з оточення Зеленського до російської агентури.
В Офісі президента лише обмежилися відповіддю радника зі стратегічних комунікацій Михайла Подоляка,
що всі звинувачення на адресу президента і його оточення є "бездоказовими словами".
Подоляк заявив, що Андрій Єрмак ніколи і за жодних обставин не міг керувати розвідкою і тим більше якимись спецопераціями.
А начальник ГУР міноборони Буданов, коментуючи розслідування Bellingcat, заявив,
що керівник Офісу президента не може втручатися у проведення спеціальних заходів розвідки.
У будь-якому випадку, тепер м'яч на полі української юстиції.